Vous savez quels sont
LES MEILLEURS
conseils qu’on peut vous donner
pour rester en bonne santé ?
ÉVITEZ
la cigarette,
les nuits courtes,
la malbouffe,
la sédentarité,
l’isolement,
etc.
Vous voyez
où je veux en venir ?
Ce sont exclusivement
des conseils NÉGATIFS
— ce sont des choses
à NE PAS FAIRE.
L’idée derrière,
c’est que,
quel que soit le domaine
où l’on cherche à s’améliorer,
la manière LA PLUS EFFICACE
de progresser,
c’est D’ABORD
DE RETIRER
ce qui nuit.
C’est ce qu’on appelle
la VIA NEGATIVA.
C’est une méthode intellectuelle
issue de la réflexion
de théologiens du Moyen-Orient
qui ont trouvé plus facile de décrire Dieu
en partant de
CE QU’IL N’EST PAS.
Intéressant…
Et si on appliquait cette méthode
à la dissertation ?
Comment est-ce que j’ai trouvé
les cinq pires défauts ?
Eh bien,
j’ai lu et corrigé
BEAUCOUP
de copies
— principalement des copies
de concours,
parce que je veux donner
à mes élèves
les meilleurs conseils
POUR LES CONCOURS.
Je connais aussi personnellement
des correcteurs,
donc je sais
ce qu’ils DÉTESTENT
dans une dissertation.
Je sais aussi qu’il y a une chose
qu’ils valorisent
PLUS QUE TOUT
en dissertation :
LA MÉTHODOLOGIE.
Ça tombe bien :
j’ai ce qu’il vous faut !
Inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Il y a déjà plus de
TRENTE MILLE
élèves
qui l’ont suivi,
donc je sais
que vous ne serez pas déçus.
MAIS ne partez pas
tout de suite
— vous découvrirez mon cours
de méthodologie
plus tard.
Regardez ATTENTIVEMENT
cette vidéo jusqu’au bout,
parce qu’éviter les PIRES
défauts
est la manière
LA PLUS EFFICACE
de progresser en dissertation.
ÉVITEZ DONC
les cinq défauts
que je vais lister
et vous gagnerez plusieurs points
DÈS
votre prochaine dissertation.
Parfois,
quand j’ouvre le fichier PDF
que m’a envoyé
un de mes élèves,
je me dis :
« Oh putain...
».
Je n’ai pas lu
UN SEUL MOT
de sa copie,
que je suis déjà désespéré.
Elle est difficile à lire,
mal aérée,
donc JE SAIS,
J’ANTICIPE
que je vais devoir faire un effort
RIEN QUE
pour réussir à lire la dissertation.
Donc une mauvaise lisibilité,
et plus généralement
une mauvaise présentation,
c’est CATASTROPHIQUE
parce que ça crée
un BIAIS DE CONFIRMATION
négatif.
Le correcteur
a un a priori NÉGATIF
sur votre dissertation
AVANT MÊME
d’en avoir lu
UN SEUL MOT !
En pratique,
c’est comme si votre copie
n’était plus notée sur VINGT,
mais sur seize,
voire sur quinze.
Vous commencez avec
UN GROS
handicap.
C’est comme si
vous vous rendiez à un entretien
sans vous être lavé
depuis plusieurs jours,
et avec des habits sales :
MÊME si vous êtes
charismatique,
ça va être compliqué
de séduire le jury.
Donc si vous voulez ÉVITER
de partir avec un handicap,
SOIGNEZ
la présentation de votre copie.
PENSEZ
au correcteur :
écrivez BIEN LISIBLEMENT,
évitez les ratures,
SUBDIVISEZ
votre rédaction en paragraphes,
et AÉREZ
votre dissertation.
D’accord ?
Allez,
défaut numéro deux !
Parfois,
je lis la copie d’un de mes élèves,
et je me dis :
« Hé,
mais ça ferait
une bonne fiche de cours,
ça.
Je la garderais bien,
cette copie.
»
MAIS c’est mauvais signe,
parce qu’une dissertation
NE DOIT PAS
ressembler à une fiche de cours !
LE DEUXIÈME
pire défaut en dissertation,
c’est donc de réciter son cours.
C’est catastrophique,
parce que ça révèle
que vous n’avez
PAS COMPRIS
CE QU’EST
l’exercice de la dissertation.
Je vous répète
ce que j’ai dit
dans pas mal de vidéos :
la dissertation N’EST PAS
un contrôle de connaissances.
C’est un exercice de RÉFLEXION
et D’EXPRESSION ÉCRITE.
Pour bien comprendre
les enjeux de la dissertation,
allez voir ma vidéo intitulée
« Qu’est-ce qu’une dissertation ? »
(vous la trouverez facilement
sur cette chaîne YouTube).
Alors,
qu’est-ce que vous devez faire
pour éviter ce défaut ?
Eh bien
c’est une question
de PRIORISATION :
ne pensez pas
EXPLICITEMENT
à partir de vos connaissances,
mais donnez la priorité
AUX ARGUMENTS,
AUX IDÉES
qui permettent de répondre
au problème intellectuel
de la dissertation
— les connaissances doivent venir
EN DERNIER,
POUR CRÉDIBILISER
vos éléments de réponse.
C’est tout pour ce deuxième défaut,
on passe au suivant !
Ce défaut,
vous le connaissez bien :
c’est un peu votre hantise,
en dissertation.
C’est…
LE HORS-SUJET !
Pourquoi est-ce que
c’est GRAVE,
le hors-sujet ?
Eh bien
parce que ça veut dire
que VOUS NE TRAITEZ PAS
le sujet qu’on vous a donné
— vous visez à côté.
Alors certes,
quand vous commettez un hors-sujet,
vous ne déballez pas votre cours,
vous avez compris
que vous devez réfléchir,
MAIS vous réfléchissez MAL !
Pour le dire plus précisément,
il vous manque la qualité
LA PLUS IMPORTANTE
de la réflexion :
la PERTINENCE.
Et encore une fois,
c’est GRAVE,
parce que la pertinence,
c’est la qualité qui garantit
L’EFFICACITÉ
de la communication humaine.
C’est la pertinence qui garantit
LA BONNE CIRCULATION
de l’information
dans la société.
Si je vous demande l’heure,
vous n’allez pas me répondre
« il fait douze degrés » !
Eh bien
c’est pareil en dissertation :
UNE QUESTION
vous est posée
— c’est votre problématique —
alors répondez
LE PLUS
précisément possible
à cette question.
Comment faire,
en pratique ?
Je vous dis quoi faire
dans la vidéo qui s’intitule
« trois astuces
pour éviter le hors-sujet »
(vous la trouverez facilement
sur cette chaîne YouTube).
Mais ne la regardez pas maintenant,
parce que vous devez
À TOUT PRIX
éviter les deux derniers défauts !
Je me souviens bien :
il y a deux ans,
je suis resté bloqué
en lisant,
enfin EN ESSAYANT
de lire une annonce de plan.
C’était la première copie
que m’avait donnée à corriger
un de mes élèves.
Je relisais,
et je relisais encore
l’annonce de plan,
et je me disais :
« Mais c’est pas possible,
je comprends rien.
Qu’est-ce que j’ai ? »
Comme le sujet de la dissertation
était sur la conscience,
l’élève avait BOURRÉ
son plan
de jargon philosophique,
et c’était INCOMPRÉHENSIBLE !
Il avait cherché à m’impressionner,
mais il a réussi l’inverse !
LE QUATRIÈME
pire défaut en dissertation,
c’est donc L’OBSCURITÉ
du style.
C’est catastrophique
parce que les correcteurs
valorisent L’INVERSE :
LA CLARTÉ
du style.
Ils SURNOTENT
même les copies
qu’ils peuvent lire
FACILEMENT.
Alors,
qu’est-ce que vous pouvez faire
pour éviter de transformer
la lecture de votre copie
en un exercice de traduction ?
Dans l’esprit de la via negativa,
la priorité,
c’est d’éviter les défauts de style.
Mon élève,
lui,
abusait du jargon,
mais vous devez plus généralement
éviter d’employer les termes
que vous ne maîtrisez pas parfaitement.
Pour PURIFIER
votre style,
évitez également
les phrases trop longues,
les formulations compliquées,
ou encore les adverbes.
Et si vous voulez améliorer votre style
en vue de la dissertation,
regardez ma vidéo qui s’intitule
« Les 3 secrets
pour améliorer son style »
(vous la trouverez facilement
sur cette chaîne YouTube).
Allez,
CINQUIÈME
et dernier défaut !
Souvent,
quand je lis vos e-mails
— et je lis TOUS LES E-MAILS
que je reçois —
souvent quand je lis vos e-mails,
je m’arrache les cheveux !
Il y a plusieurs fautes par phrase,
quasiment pas de ponctuation,
ni d’accents
— et parfois vous ne mettez
MÊME PAS
de majuscule
à mon prénom !
Alors,
c’est vrai que certains élèves
écrivent correctement,
mais ils sont vraiment
une minorité.
Vous faites mauvaise impression
quand vous commettez des fautes
dans un e-mail,
mais en dissertation
C’EST PIRE,
parce que c’est un exercice
d’expression écrite !
Si vous vous dites
« Les fautes
c’est pas grave,
ce qui compte,
ce sont les idées. »
— si vous vous dites ça,
vous vous trompez
LOURDEMENT !
Vous vous trompez lourdement
parce que les fautes d’expression
sont un défaut
probablement PIRE
qu’une mauvaise présentation
(le premier des cinq défauts).
Pourquoi ?
Parce que la correction de la langue
est une chose SACRÉE
pour le correcteur.
La langue française,
c’est son outil de travail,
c’est probablement son obsession,
et vous,
vous la négligez,
vous vous en servez
comme si ça n’avait pas de valeur !
Vous risquez donc de créer
un biais de confirmation PIRE
que celui créé
par une mauvaise présentation :
vous risquez de vous attirer
LE MÉPRIS
du correcteur.
J’espère que je vous ai convaincus,
parce que
si vous faites beaucoup de fautes,
ce ne sera pas seulement le correcteur
qui vous méprisera,
mais aussi plus tard,
dans votre vie professionnelle,
vos supérieurs,
vos collègues
— en fait
TOUTES LES PERSONNES
auxquelles vous écrirez.
Alors,
comment faire moins de fautes ?
Je vous recommande trois choses.
LA PREMIÈRE,
c’est de vous surveiller vous-même
PLUS ATTENTIVEMENT
lorsque vous écrivez
— et cela
QUEL QUE SOIT
le texte que vous écrivez.
Un petit message
ou un commentaire,
ce n’est pas une excuse
pour se laisser aller.
LA DEUXIÈME
chose à faire,
c’est de vérifier SYSTÉMATIQUEMENT
lorsque vous avez un doute.
En plus,
aujourd’hui c’est très facile :
vous tapez
ce que vous voulez vérifier
dans Google,
et vous avez la réponse
en quelques secondes.
TROISIÈME
chose à faire :
RELISEZ-VOUS !
Non seulement vous devez
prévoir quelques minutes de relecture
à la fin de l’épreuve de dissertation,
mais vous avez intérêt
à vous relire
QUEL QUE SOIT
le texte que vous écrivez !
Vous allez peut-être
me trouver extrême,
mais je n’envoie JAMAIS
un e-mail,
ni même un simple message
de quelques mots
SANS
l’avoir relu
AU MOINS
une fois.
Et c’est la raison principale
pour laquelle je fais TRÈS PEU
de fautes.
Donc corrigez les e-mails
que vous m’écrivez,
et vous verrez que vous ferez
moins de fautes
en dissertation.
Ça y est,
vous connaissez
LES CINQ
pires défauts
à éviter en dissertation :
une présentation de copie
désagréable,
le déballage du cours,
le hors-sujet,
l’obscurité du style,
et enfin,
les fautes d’expression.
Plutôt que de vous focaliser
sur des détails,
évitez À TOUT PRIX
ces cinq défauts,
et vous réaliserez
DE GROS PROGRÈS
en dissertation.
Et si vous voulez progresser
ENCORE PLUS VITE,
inscrivez-vous
à mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Et puis si vous voulez
me signaler les défauts
de cette vidéo,
vous pouvez le faire
dans les commentaires.
En tout cas,
j’espère vraiment
qu’elle vous sera UTILE
malgré ses défauts.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour progresser RAPIDEMENT
en dissertation.